news broke this week that jake paul and
logan paul are thinking about buying
brand new penthouse units in the 11
residents beyond tower in downtown miami
each one of these units goes for 21
million dollars these guys are
absolutely killing it now before we talk
about the building itself jake and logan
have taken the world by storm these guys
started out they were on disney channel
then all of a sudden they were youtube
sensations and now they've turned into
full-fledged real players both in
entrepreneurship and investing and in
the boxing world logan stepped in the
ring with floyd mayweather one of the
best boxers to ever do it jake's knocked
out every single fighter that he's
fought in the ring both of them are
making millions of dollars a year and
they're investing in everything from
companies to nfts to various projects
they really really understand exactly
what they're doing not only from what
they're operating as businesses but also
from the sports world and the investing
world i'm super impressed by them and i
think most people underestimate how
intelligent they actually are but of
course now they're looking to buy these
penthouse units in downtown miami and so
the 11 beyond building is absolutely
breathtaking here's a couple of photos
of the renderings of what is being built
this is the inside of one of the units
it literally looks like an awesome
modern version of an old school library
just something that you sit and you're
like yeah i made it you're sitting in
the sky and absolutely balling out and
then of course they've got a pool deck
and what's unique about this pool deck
is that they're building it just like a
las vegas pool party scene they've got
everything from a huge dj booth to the
pool it's overlooking the downtown
nightlife everything that you could ever
want in a pool deck they got going on at
the 11 beyond residence building now how
the hell do i know so much about this
building my friend mark roberts and his
partners are the ones that are actually
developing it and it is absolutely
awesome now they also have created this
brand new virtual reality tour that you
can take i've been fortunate enough to
take it also jake and logan went and
they did it as well and when you go
through this vr tour what you get to see
is you get to literally walk out there
on the pool deck and see exactly what's
happening you get to go through the
lobby you get to go into the units and
you can walk around go through the
living room into the bedrooms the
bathroom see what the kitchen's like go
out onto the balcony anything that you
would need to understand before you
actually make the purchase you can do
through vr that's what's so special
about this not only is the building got
a great location in downtown miami not
only is the building absolutely
breathtaking but also when you add in
experiences like this through the vr
experience now all of a sudden people
can feel like they know exactly what
they're buying so jake and logan paul
taking the world by storm absolutely
crushing it in 2021 now they're thinking
about buying these penthouse units and i
gotta say i wouldn't be surprised if
this is the first of many things that
they start to do as they become more and
more successful i'm excited to see what
happens with the 11 residents beyond
tower and i can't wait to see all of us
crush it more in 2022